bonjour et merci d'être avec nous sur rt
france sur la forme déjà quel est selon
vous le soft de cette visite de mike
pompéo en france lors on peut
effectivement s'interroger sur le sens
de cette visite
imaginez bien qu à ce niveau lorsqu'il
ya une visite diplomatique ce n'est pas
simplement pour prendre le thé surtout
que ça n'est pas une prise de fonction
pour marc dumas pour monsieur pompéo et
donc on imagine mal sur les dossiers en
suspens on pense à l'irak on pense à
l'afghanistan on pense à la question
iranienne
on pense au sujet de terrorisme on
imagine mal le le secrétaire d'état
américain prenant des engagements tout
état de cause on peut comprendre la
difficulté qu'il aurait à prendre des
engagements qui seraient des engagements
en pointillés parce que ce ne sont pas
des sujets des sujets qui de court terme
ce sont des sujets évidemment de long de
moyen et long terme
or on sait qu'il y a un problème en fait
qui n'est pas un problème on sait qu'il
ya probablement une transition de
gouvernement d'administration et donc ça
met un peu en difficulté ou en tout cas
ça peut poser question près du
gouvernement français auprès des
interlocuteurs d'une manière générale de
de monsieur pompéo sur la réalité des
engagements qu'il pourrait être amené à
prendre au nom des états unis parce
qu'il ya un risque
je dis bien il y un risque qu'il ne soit
plus aux affaires à partir du 20 janvier
je pense qu'il faut quand même préciser
que il est il reste en tout cas le
président trump reste comme président
jusqu'au 20 janvier donc jusqu'au 20
janvier
il peut prendre des mesures d'urgence
dans le cadre de sa politique étrangère
sans peux très bien comprendre et ça ne
doit pas être discutée sur le plan
juridique et institutionnel en revanche
sur les sujets de moyen long terme c'est
vrai que les engagements qui pourraient
être pris côté américain où les demandes
qui pourraient être formulées peuvent
prêter à discussion
alors va revenir à dans un instant sur
le fond de ces échanges mais du côté des
manuels macro est ce que c'est un jeu
d'équilibriste
las pour le chef de l'état il reçoit lé
chef actuel de la diplomatie américaine
qui ne reconnaît donc pas la défaite de
donald trump tout ce temps se tournant
déjà vers sa relation avec le futur
président en tout cas celui qui a été
annoncé vainqueur à la présidentielle
des états unis joe biden qui l'a appelé
pour le féliciter
emmanuel macron marche sur des oeufs
j'ai presque envie de vous dire il fait
exactement ce que doit faire dans tous
les cas un chef de gouvernement
responsable d'une part le gouvernement
français ne peut pas s'ingérer dans la
bataille pour la succession à la
présidence des états unis
on sait en tout cas que suivant un
modèle relativement italie ces jo baden
qui a été désigné il y à une
contestation judiciaire et juridique
cette contestation sera vidée au plus
tard le 14 décembre avec l'élection des
ducs du président la désignation du
président ou la réélection pourquoi pas
du président sortant mais entre temps le
président dont il est obligé de recevoir
marque pour eux monsieur pompéo parce
qu'il s'agit du secrétaire d'état
américain en titre il y as continuité du
gouvernement américain il y as
continuité des institutions mais il ne
peut pas ignorer qu'il y a une
possibilité que l'administration 30 ne
soit plus aux responsabilités à partir
du 20 janvier
le 20 janvier vous savez c'est loin mais
c'est en même temps très court
donc il est obligée d'engager les
conversations avec avec l'équipe de
transition du président élu du président
byden je pense à monsieur blinken je
pense à madame susan rice
mais la menace est un membre de la
commission de transition c'est donc j'ai
envie de dire parfaitement normal c'est
en rendant le respect des institutions
et puis parce qu'il ne peut pas attendre
la france où les partenaires des états
unis ne peuvent pas attendre le 20
janvier pour pouvoir imaginer ce que
l'on doit faire d'image il est très bon
la politique étrangère nécessite que
l'on ne soit pas uniquement
exclusivement en attente de
deux décisions qui seront prises dans
trois ou quatre voire dans cinq semaines
voire des mois dans le cas d'espèce est
qu'il ya une situation qui nécessite
qu'on y travaille en amont sur le fond
sur quoi doivent rapporter les
discussions aujourd'hui entre mike
pompéo emmanuel macron notamment on
évoque le dossier iranien celui de
l'afghanistan aussi quelles sont les
intentions
sur ces deux points d'administration
trappe alors le tout à l'heure lorsque
se disait que ça n'était pas le une
prise de fonctions de monsieur pompéo et
donc les positions américaines sont
relativement connu puisque il le
gouvernement américain sous la
présidence se trouve à dix on sort de
l'accord sur le nucléaire iranien
on se retire assez rapidement d'où l'on
retire notre ou d'asie centrale
on parle d'afghanistan là non pas de
l'irak
voilà donc à partir de ce moment là on
voit dès que la position elle est connue
le lie à une différents une divergence
d'appréciation de la part du
gouvernement français qui auraient
souhaité en tout état de cause
un retrait qui ne soit pas aussi
immédiat pas aussi brutale parce que ça
met en jeu la stabilité ça peut même
être en à risques la stabilité dans la
région qui est déjà encore très précaire
donc on voit bien qu'il y a des
désaccords les discussions porteront là
dessus et je reste persuadé que le
président français ne manquera pas
d'interpeller son interlocuteur sur la
précipitation
en tout cas sur le retrait et sur la
nécessité en revanche de reconsidérer la
position américaine si le gouvernement
d'administration trompe
or on ne sait pas un peu netapp ou
succès à la tête du gouvernement
américain de reconsidérer la position à
l'égard des iraniens je pense que le 12
oui oui mais remercie pardon de le temps
le temps file à doha l'occasion de
prolonger cet échange jean-claude de la
bauge au vice président du cercle de
réflexion france amérique
et